[Musica]
Ciao ragazzi benvenuti in una nuova
puntata di vita buttata Oggi ho l'onore
di avere arte all'interno di quelli che
sono gli Studios degli Studios di vita
buttata abbiamo l'odore Albi dello Stato
Sociale e in mezzo a loro così così
nuovo membro Ok così Valerio angione
Ragazzi grazie mille per essere miei
ospiti prima di partire Grazie
[Musica]
Allora ragazzi allora prima ancora di
buttarci in quella che sarà la puntata
di oggi io Volevo innanzitutto fare dei
complimenti fai dei complimenti a una
ragazza che mi è vincitrice dopo un anno
di tournetti teatrale con uno spettacolo
che ha fatto riparto da me
Valeria tu mi Vinci addirittura un
premio su ticketmaster giusto cioè
uno spettacolo teatrale la rifaccio
aspetta la rifaccio
Se continui un sorso e già è uno
spettacolo teatrale però voi vi direte
Ok ma che c'entriamo noi con Valeria
invece c'è un gioco c'è un lavoro
proprio filologico perché Perché voi so
che state uscendo con ritorno alle
origini E effettivamente
riparto da me è un po' un suo ritornare
ripercorrere quella che un pochino stata
la sua storia vita è sempre stato uno
show Ok che ha messo in piazza quelli
che sono i fatti delle persone e noi
Difatti dei nostri follower di chi ci
segue Ne parleremo Ma ne parleremo dopo
quello che vorremmo fare adesso invece è
per mettere tutti quanti voi di pescare
un bigliettino partendo
Ok Questi sono tutti quanti i temi
storici di Questo format per cui questa
volta con i nostri ospiti invece di
commentare audio noi commenteremo
direttamente i fatti tuoi live
mi sono perso nel décolleté mentre Spero
di aver preso uno carino eh la cosa più
stupida che hai mai fatto Cazzo che è
difficile lasciala decantare lasciate
cantare perché abbiamo capito che se la
forzi non arriva
a un certo punto Ok nel frattempo tu
puoi scatene un altro un sogno assurdo
che hai fatto questo ce l'ho anche
recente Vai parliamone a parte così Ma
sì partiamo con te Dai allora ho sognato
recentemente ho sognato di essere morto
ed ero una sorta di non fantasma perché
ero vivo in carne ossa in un mondo dove
i VIP nello stesso mondo che abitiamo
non c'erano le persone vive c'erano solo
tutti gli altri morti e però il mondo
era lo stesso però io avevo la
consapevolezza di essere morto avevo
coscientemente ero morto quindi il mio
unico obiettivo all'interno
di questo sogno era riuscire a
comunicare col mondo dei vivi Quindi
cercavo di lasciare dei segni tipo
grattavo delle scrivevo delle cose su
delle lavagne lasciamo così sì facciamo
delle cose lasciavo dei bigliettini che
però riuscivo a capire che non venivano
percepite nel mondo dei vivi ed ero
anziso perché non riuscivo a comunicare
con in questo caso mia moglie che volevo
dirle sto bene non ti preoccupare Sono
morto ma sto bene Secondo me è molto
profondo Io invece una serie No io
invece una volta volevo ho sognato che
volevo fare del sesso con una donna non
aveva il preservativo e mi chiedevo se
utilizzando il domopak avrebbe potuto
creare lo stesso effetto Cioè per farti
capire il livello
Infatti siedo più basso di te non so se
lo vedi è un pochino come Davanti al re
bello però cioè secondo me è più bello
del mio parlare con mia moglie per farle
capire che sto bene nell'aldilà e
lasciare dei messaggi
domopak sul cazzo capisci la vita in
mezzo c'è la vita e l'interlocutore era
sempre sua moglie
Sì
casualmente è un medico e potrebbe
rispondere a questa tua domanda bisogna
sempre le stesse cose che mi cadono i
denti di volare perché ho paura di
volare di andare in giro per strada non
avere le scarpe o di andare a scuola
elementari ed essere nudo di sotto e poi
ogni tanto sogno tipo delle canzoni dei
film delle cose Provo a svegliarmi a
segnarmi le cose e e ed è una delle
esperienze più deludenti le frustranti
dell'esistenza perché nel sogno Sono
esattamente dei capolavori della musica
e poi lo rivedi scritto con Ho delle
cose segnate dopo lo trovo lo rivedi
scritto così poi con anche il no gli
occhi Ci sposi e il tentativo di dire
delle cose sintetiche perché poi ti
saresti ricordato Insomma fanno schifo
ste canzoni Io ho scelto questa cioè mi
hai scelto
il tuo talento nascosto Mmm io riesco a
anche tu penso creare da una situazione
maniera assurda un video scrivere
scrivere una sceneggiatura ci sono
capace di fare questa non è nascosto
Cioè tu fai l'opposto di quello che fa
l'odore Cioè tu riesci a trasformare in
qualcosa di compiuto un qualcosa che non
ha senso lui invece su ogni bellissimi
li trasforma in orribili realtà il mio
talento nascosto è questo comunque saper
fare questo
fallo
[Musica]
questa questo è il mio talento nascosto
Aspetta che la faccio
Madonna che impressione
abbiamo visto noi chiudo la palpebra
sembra una bambola satanica presente
Lo sai fare No queste sopracciglia
si muove il muscolo
non Devo esercitarmi in un bar di
provincia potrebbe succedermi qualsiasi
cosa Lodo finisci tu e poi passiamo un
giochetto che facciamo insieme amici di
merda Vabbè in realtà c'è anche da dire
che questa è il miglior Gin tonic
analcolico che abbiamo bevuto e Ma te lo
possono versare un pochino dell'altro mi
piace ci sono queste super buone questa
cosa eh scusate Sai dov'è L'ultima volta
che ho che ho bevuto un gin tonic in una
casa alcolico analcolico
anche in questo caso analcolico in una
tazza a X Factor non ci credo
con la x sopra
acqua così e tu sei in tensione così non
sai passano i tuoi non passano i tuoi a
un certo punto finisce la puntata e sono
passati tutti quanti e tu cominci a
muoverti a dire ma Io prenderei ogni
tonica adesso e ti arriva questo Gin
tonic ghiacciatissimo e cominci a bere a
star lì a pensare Ho fatto i miei
compiti la mia band in finale va tutto
benissimo E in quel momento Federico ti
fa Ti fa ti fa decidere al tilt se se
deve uscire uno o un altro l'ultima
puntata veramente
ha fatto ha pareggiato Quindi io ci
avevo il quel tilt e avevo appena
portato la mia band in finale e stavo da
Dio e stavo bevendo il mio genitore sei
felice tu ieri stavo bevendo il mio
genitore con mano di fianco anche lui
col suo genitore noi lì a farci la
nostra balotta stavamo da Dio ragazzi è
tutto molto bello però forse è arrivato
il momento di passare a i fatti
all'interno di vita buttata C'è sempre
un momento di ho deciso di sfidarvi
avremo due scatole in una c'è una
canzone famosa Nell'altra c'è uno
strumento quello dovremmo fare noi è a
giro suonare e gli altri tre dovranno
indovinare prima degli altri è
bellissimo la canzone inizio io per
farvi capire io prendo così uno
strumento tutti voi lo potete vedere
Ukulele
È una canzone
era quella
è uscito questo io non so come si suoni
puoi anche tamburellarlo
e mettere il braccio dentro
il buco dentro il buco
Allora
[Musica]
sei compiuto perché Tanti auguri tanti
auguri a te no
[Musica]
Questo è un momento che parla della
morte
[Musica]
Mamma mia No
è vero È vero È vero bravo
in tutti i modi ero così Gollum
accartoccia capito Però avevi questa
faccia era difficile concentrarsi con la
tua faccia
Allora posso quindi adesso tocca a te
[Applauso]
Esatto anche come si muove col corpo poi
no Hai indovinato di nuovo Basta
[Musica]
ce l'hai
No è impossibile vai
Nessun dorma
[Applauso]
Bohemian Rhapsody no raga
ho bisogno di muovermi Aspetta eh faccio
anche il movimento
dalle sue Entrate Wind
[Musica]
No ma non so fare le note uguali
[Applauso]
volare nella versione di Gipsy King No
mamma mia
[Musica]
la sigla della corrida naso perché così
è diversa dai
Allora vi do un indizio ma la
protagonista che la canta è bionda e ha
molto freddo
Frozen voi non conoscete nessuno essere
vivente che abbia mai avuto meno di 8
anni
c'è stata bravissima No non c'è nessuno
che c'era comunque no se volevamo
scendere io non lo sapevo Di cosa si
sente parlare Grazie
flauto bellissimo se viene fuori Fra
Martino Che bello
Qualcosa mi dice che non è uscito Fra
Martino
Campana perché è proprio cioè è proprio
è lei
non è vero C'è Fra Martino No non ci
voglio credere
[Musica]
alla fine
nacchere nacchere decapitato
hai rotto il cazzo questa ce l'ho
lo so prego faccio come se ci fossero le
note faccio solo con la velocità delle
note
Io ce l'ho sulla punta della lingua
non so il titolo
Allora possiamo dire Ukulele il nostro
sbloccato
[Musica]
che malinconia ragazzi
è quasi è quasi drammatico
Maracaibo ma
no L'ho capito dalle nacchere in realtà
perché mi stavo continuando la roba del
genere
Ah cazzo Ginetto al volo e ci vediamo
alla prossima tutto il giorno no il
problema triangolo
le facce le loro facce dobbiamo guardare
guarda guarda come lui ci aveva regalato
qualcosa
[Musica]
ah
sembri molto arrabbiato molto innamorato
io non sto capendo nulla
[Musica]
di prima pensavo di sapere ma
Ah beh beh beh
ho capito
Tocca a me sì
Ok vai al flauto ragazzi disinfettiamo
il flauto
questo con il flauto
e la macarena ritmica
niente con la Macarena
adoro dai Tamburello Oh non stai
Smeralda Falla vedere va'
No faccio vedere dopo perché questa così
la indovina un altro ok
ritmicamente valido sia ritmicamente
molto valido
io non ho capito nulla
Questo è il pezzo che secondo me ti
dovrebbe far capire
ecco
qua ok
Aspetta che la devo cercare bello molto
bella Io gliela farei vedere
bravissimo bravissimo è l'ultima canzone
mi sa
[Musica]
tutto
tutto tutto tutto tutto
[Musica]
si capisce un cazzo non si vede uno che
si diverte Cioè infatti facciamolo
vedere
Guarda come sapete
[Musica]
fan Girl come hai fatto tutta la strofa
Ma che senso
avete giocato al gioco più divertente
che ho mai fatto nella mia vita una via
ragazzi a questo punto io direi che
siamo quasi in chiusura abbiamo fatto
un'analisi di quello che è stato il
vostro percorso ma noi non abbiamo poi
parlato di questo album ritorni alle
origini poi alla fine
di una ragazza che ha messo in scena la
propria storia abbiamo parlato e poi
dentro non ne abbiamo parlato parliamo
in un secondo Lo monteremo prima per
finta quindi toglile E poi voglio
l'atmosfera e poi risuonalo cioè
nascondino
dietro benissimo quindi
Fingi che siamo all'inizio
di cosa Raccontami di questo di questo
progetto
[Musica]
ritorna alle origini è un nome che gli
abbiamo dato adesso perché in realtà non
si chiama così in realtà non abbiamo
ancora un nome per questo disco che sta
per uscire però perché abbiamo pensato
che se ci mettevamo una scadenza poi
saremo riusciti a portare a compimento
le cose e in realtà non è stato così
però però abbiamo creato un tour di cose
che facciamo suonando presente quella
roba che si suona e che lo faremo
suonando in anteprima un disco
che non esiste cioè che abbiamo quasi
finito però in realtà non esiste quindi
si chiama tour di anteprima di un disco
bellissimo quindi potrebbe anche
crescere e nascere quel ed evolversi
quel disco durante questo tour
Esattamente eh Anche se in realtà
l'avremo già finito consegnato Però è
bello crederci La magia è bella così
però io potevi dirmi di sì e farmici
credere credere
dobbiamo consegnare un disco fra un mese
Noi non sappiamo cosa stiamo facendo
niente quest'anno ho fissato delle date
han detto che facciamo delle cose e noi
non abbiamo il titolo non sappiamo quali
sono le canzoni Non non abbiamo finito
di fare niente Però a gennaio è un mese
buono per i rapimenti ci rapiranno e ci
faranno scrivere delle cose le
consegneremo e a quel punto qualcuno
penserà che le abbiamo scritto di nostra
spontanea volontà in realtà non vogliamo
assolutamente Tornare alle Origini non
voleva assolutamente per noi volevamo
noi volevamo passare anche non fare
niente siamo in questa fase No
per capitalismo globale
diciamolo siamo in questa fase
perché ha permesso comunque di avervi
qui perché giustamente questo qui è uno
sterile è uno sterile rappresentanza
possiamo dirlo detto ciò ora puoi
ritirare fuori il il divertirti
ora
[Musica]
Ti prego ti prego ritorna a fare quello
no perché vedere un sorriso strappato in
questo modo per me è un crimine detto
ciò io ho fatto una richiesta alle
persone per collegare sempre i puntini
dell'inizio ossia
ritorno alle origini che poi non si
torna Eh non si va da nessuna parte
Cioè non sappiamo poi dove sei andata
questa situazione Io ho fatto una
domanda molto semplice legata a il
rapporto che le persone hanno coi loro
genitori e quindi con genitori con
figure genitoriali strane per cui
abbiamo dei messaggi da parte delle
persone che condivideranno con noi cose
che hanno fatto i genitori Voi comunque
avete aneddoti legati ai vostri
c'è veramente penso di essere proprio
inutile con questo tema perché ho due
genitori che veramente normalissimi
quindi ciao al massimo mia madre canta
Ai karaoke imbarazza tutta la famiglia
sempre quella canzone di Patty Pravo
Come si chiama bravo bravo
bravo
Vale allora scambio culturale con la
Francia viene da noi una ragazza e mia
madre le spiega come si usa il bidet
la prima cosa prima Allora in pratica
allora allora allora tu adesso non entri
in questa casa ci vediamo dalla finestra
del cesso Sapete perché i francesi non
hanno il bidet ma la parola bidet
francese sapete lo sapevo ma l'ho
dimenticato perché il bidet è stato
inventato a Napoli
quindi secondo me potrebbe anche essere
una parola napoletana
Comunque andiamo avanti Ogni fidanzato
io e mia sorella abbiamo portato a casa
Mio padre l'ha minacciato con l'accetta
la zeppa
Quello era un altro video era più una
sfida che è una minaccia cioè ogni
fidanzato dico due sorelle Queste sono
intanto ma soprattutto ogni fidanzato
vuol dire che quelli di prima che cosa
gli è successo da cui fidanzato di sta
ceppa
di staccetta
io ho capito veramente ceppa comunque
che dire a questa ragazza qualche
consiglio vogliamo Vai a vivere da sola
cioè banalmente nascondi l'accetta tuo
padre bravo oppure Trasferisciti in
città non abitare in un bosco
è vero perché chi chi accetta possono
sempre peggio questa questa puntata No
no fidati di continuo collegamento
ho scoperto che mio padre scriveva alla
ex di mio fratello se potevano vedersi
di nascosto queste cose queste pensavo
io Capito queste cose elettrizzardine io
non saprei proprio cosa fare sarei così
immobile
alla sorella che ha bisogno di un
consiglio no Ah ah ah poi alla fine non
c'entra niente se no il fatto che è
dentro la famiglia ma perché il fratello
c'entra qualcosa mica No ho capito
signora signora
potrebbe recuperare l'accetta da quello
di prima ragazzi che dirvi Io vi
ringrazio Qui abbiamo tre linee da
prendere treni da perdere ma soprattutto
dobbiamo tutti quanti di partire da un
posto tu da Termini e da noi ma Valeria
da se stessa
Grazie a tutti voi Ci vediamo la
prossima puntata di vita buttata Uh
Trionfo
[Musica]